this man had me at hello when i first
saw him in kingdom and then he came on
our studio to promote it
because we were born on audience and so
is kingdom which is such a dynamite show
and then he is just so terrific and
absolutely everything that he
he's done sitting on a city on a hill
justified
uh and and i say that even though when
he came on this show and he tried to
flush
my new york yankee hat down the toilet
because he's a die-hard red sox fan
he did so uh tonight a new episode of
debris airs tonight at 10 pm eastern on
nbc
debris about the argument that red sox
fans are left with
when they find out that mookie betts is
left for the dodgers
jonathan tucker here on the rich eisen
show is that what is that is that what
debris is about
i have a few things to say to you but
let me just start with this i got a few
things
one yes one yes you
crush mondays it's just a day where
other people are slacking
and rich ice icing just comes in so
strong
and accomplishes the goals it is a
miracle
and an inspiration to watch so thank you
you should just say you're welcome
yes the second thing i'd like to say i
was thinking about you this morning i
was like
you know you really you are doing you're
really doing it right man
okay i mean you kind of like do what you
want
when you want your you you have you have
an amazing show
in like you're in sports you want to go
see a game you get
access to it you have an incredible
healthy family your wife whom i've
gotten the opportunity to meet yeah
she loves total smoke show
she is beautiful she's also incredibly
smart entrepreneurial
totally dynamic entirely on our own
right you're living in southern
california
you're a handsome man thank you things
are going very
very well for richard eisen
so that means you don't want to talk
about mookie bets
or is that what that means or i mean
what a way to throw a weapon
on a knife on a nice opening on a nice
opening diet
you know i think you know you know we
feel about monkey back
we put we we actually put in our own fan
money
into a sign sending him uh a hope
did didn't you see that goodbye mookie
beck uh something that they put up
i did jonathan yeah i did go get him get
him get him out of here get him out of
here
jonathan tucker everybody here on the
rich eisen show
i do bring it on mondays because i just
it's it's what happens when i
escape my children after being cooped up
with them for two days you know what i
mean like i just come here and it's just
i just come straight out of the gate and
i just want to talk sports and just talk
about stuff
you know especially with friends it's a
winner's habit richard you gotta you
gotta you're a champion
on and off the field you show up when
everybody else is tired and sleepy eye
and you get the job done uh
you are too kind you were too kind tom
you're the tom brady
oh wow well we went to the same school
same great institution of higher
learning
michigan let's do it you know who else
is you know who else is going to
michigan this year
is um mark consuela and kelly ripa's son
is going to michigan as a freshman he
got accepted to a
a whole host of schools in the rigorous
college process okay and he chose
michigan and he's going to be wrestling
uh for university of michigan uh
next year i didn't know that he's
adopting the
team uh and i'm going to be going to as
many possible
meets as i can i've already ordered my
michigan year so you and i are finally
going to find something in good common
ground
fantastic and then so are we going to
have a show called live with kelly and
harbaugh is that we're going to have
i mean i would i'd pay i think it'd be
good to get
you know you got to get mark on to talk
about the wrestling uh
program there which is uh you know first
rate
and maybe we can all go and see his son
um joaquin
uh on the mat i did i love it we have
something in common for the university
of michigan uh
jonathan tucker here uh on the on the
rich eisen show
um so are you still attuned to mma you
still follow that from
from the kingdom world or have you moved
oh my god i can't get it out of my
system is that right
i'm just obsessed with it i can't get
another and i gotta tell you
you know dana dana white people
he you know that guy's got he he gets it
left right and center
um he's got actual senators calling him
irresponsible
and totally inappropriate and um
you know he's dead what's his name but
not jon stewart but um
john oliver you know doing a whole
segment on dana trying to put on the
the ufc back in the beginning of the
pandemic and he totally pulled it off
i mean he was the first sport back they
did it responsibly they put people back
to work
um they've taken the covenant protocols
in
you know very very uh seriously
and they've provided a forum for people
to do their jobs and to provide
entertainment for
folks around the world and credit do
where credit's due
um i think we'll look back and be really
impressed with
uh what he was able to pull off during
this challenging period who's your
favorite fighter
who do you like who do you who would you
put down good
hard-earned tucker money to say you know
what i want to watch this person
fight or at any point during you know i
i i'm really into like i love these
folks who have
um just very different styles of
fighting
like i love watching dominic cruz fight
he just
came back with a big win i love watching
folks like um
you know steven wonder boy thompson with
his like long karate stance
um i like watching you know the women
that's one of the other things about mma
that people who aren't familiar with the
sport don't really
appreciate or give credit to is that
it's like other than
tennis it's the only sport that'll
headline a woman
and sell out uh and support it with the
same advertising dollars as they would
uh for their male counterparts uh so i i
don't know the women have
incredible fighting personalities you
know just their
um you know they and maybe they feel
like they've got something more to prove
but they just
always bring it you're rarely going to
be disappointed with a
with a female fight um i just like the
different style that's what
what's so exciting about mma is that you
get all these different kinds of
fighters
from all these different backgrounds all
different colors different religions
different languages
and it doesn't matter where they came
from how much money they had or didn't
have
you know how do you step into that
octagon or that ring and what and and
who are you going to be that day
and that's um that's great jonathan
tucker here on the rich eisen show let's
talk about your show
do you think that uh in real for real
that ufos exist
do you think for real based on what do
you think you know i don't know man i'm
so concerned about like
taking care of my two two-year-old twins
and like my anxiety over packing my bags
in vancouver and getting down here to
l.a yeah i guess i just don't really
like
am i gonna you know is the irs gonna
audit me and i'm not gonna have all the
receipts
you know stand me by i got so many
concerns i'm like i don't know if
there's intelligent life form out there
come on down man let's
let's let's pow out the the uh the new
yorker had a really great piece on this
piece of debris that was flying through
the solar system recently and they're
like we really don't know
right how that was moving the way it was
moving and there's real
serious folks who think that that was a
ufo and then you got wackadoo
harry reid who turns out to kind of be
right about this
you know remember how much gus he got
yeah i know to actually talk about ufos
yeah i know right and lo and behold what
he didn't say was
hey guys i've been funneling hundreds of
millions of dollars to this program
and we've seen real stuff and people
that we actually trust the most in this
country like air force pilots
uh they have seen some things that seem
a little out of place
exactly and this show is all about you
know what's coming down from the sky
and you and um you and your your your
fellow cast members norbert leo butts
who is
one of the most talented people that
could he really is that's you know ever
been on a screen stage the whole the
whole the whole
nine yards fun stuff looks like you're
having fun doing it
jonathan uh you know i love being um i
love being employed
and i love i love working with people
that are
are not just really telling the bar is
obviously
like be talented be prepared be excited
to show up
bring new ideas but um you also want to
work with nice people
i don't know i mean how fast is your
life going by rich how fast your kids
are growing up you don't want to be
hanging around with the sort of schmoes
that you have on your show right now you
got to move on dude that adam
that guy's got to go gotta go
no i mean you want to be around nice
people you want to enjoy your life you
don't want to
be bifurcating your life between things
you accept
because they're at work and the joy you
get at home like why can't you try to
work with people who are nice
i agree with you did you just broadside
my uh call screener is that what you
just yeah adam yeah you were having a
nice chat before nice guy
you gotta fire him
[Laughter]
so you have two you have two
two-year-old twins right
yeah okay they're so great okay what is
th when when they grow
as they grow up what is the last
character you
you've played that you'd want them to
see daddy on screen as
oh god at what age i don't know i mean i
want them to be proud of me
they will be proud of you because you
absolutely crush every role you're in
jonathan but you play some people
who are a little bit shall we say off
center to say the last
my buddy before i had kids my buddy reed
bernie who's a
um an extraordinary actor he's got a
handful of tonys
um he said you know before he had kids
his biggest fear was that he'd have
these kids and his kids would be on the
school yard
and they'd be like what's your dad do
he's like oh he's an attorney oh okay
what's your dad he's the doctor all
right okay what's your dad do he's an
actor oh an actor what's his name
reed bernie read bernie
never heard of him i was like yeah
i get that that's a it's a it's a it's
totally like surface
but um you know you want your kids to be
proud of the work you're doing
to be proud of the person that you're
doing but um so i think they're going to
have to be a little older
before they watch justified before yeah
yeah
yeah i like adult fair man
oh my gosh all right so yeah so tj
jefferson uh
uh snuck with this guy he's love you too
he snuck this
uh this jonathan tucker audience sort of
star like a like a walk of fame star
that you
did you sneak this out of an office tj
is that what you did
so what you did look um
it just it ended up it ended up here
and i i showed that to tucker like two
years ago and i so i send them a picture
you want it i'll send it to you but you
know
it's i like i prefer if you put it on
your desk and keep it there so you can
look at it and think of me all day
that's what i told him when i had it he
goes you should just keep it and look
this is
exclusively licensed by the hollywood
chamber of commerce
i mean this is serious business it's
kind of safe home here okay yeah
clearly look i will take care of it but
i'll say this i love directv
i mean honestly i'm never cutting that
cord that's the first package
that it is ridiculous it's so good
you're like i want to do the commercial
for directv where my wife's like
hey we're going to brunch with my
friends from college and i'm like uh
i've got like three games i want to
watch and then like
she's looking over at me uh you know in
one take where i'm like staring at the
phone and sweating and freaking out
because i want to watch the game
and the other one is like i'm like yeah
sure honey no problem
because i've got you know the sunday
ticket and i
guarantee those games are going to be
sitting there waiting for me and the
point of fact
uh my love i'm going to leave my phone
at home
like it's such a winner of a of an
entertainment package and it is
expensive and i know how lucky i am to
be able to afford it
but it is legitimately one of the best
entertainment things that i have and the
remote control
can fast forward the exact amount of
time that it takes
the patriots to get it down so i as soon
as the ball
uh declared dead i click the button and
i'm immediately on the next play all
right fantastic
i mean that note that this this mock-up
star is worth it for
yeah give it to them and all those years
later
so good dude all right jonathan uh i
love chatting with you again a new
episode of debris airs tonight at 10
eastern time on nbc
it's about the 2020-21
boston celtics season um
next week's episode is about the
uh the brian hoyer start of 2020 for the
new england patriots
debris is a great show man so
congratulations on that
[Music]
your phone just cut out just at a
perfect time this it's also about
jonathan tucker's cell reception now
that's
[Laughter]
i just lost him i love jonathan tucker